التطعيمات عادة ما تكون
مملة بشكل روتيني ليس اليوم ،
إنها مثيرة للغاية
[تصفيق]
يقول مايكل تيبس المخضرم في الحرب العالمية الثانية
إنه لم يشعر بالإبرة
الآن أنا محظوظ جدًا حقًا آمل حقًا
أن يسقط الجميع ويحصلون عليها لأنها
حقًا  لا توجد مشكلة على الإطلاق
[تصفيق]
كان على شخص ما أن يذهب أولاً. ذهب الشرف
إلى ماجي كينان ،
الجدة البالغة من العمر 91 عامًا تقريبًا تقول أن اللقاح
هو هدية رائعة
لعيد ميلاد مبكرة ، وأقول إن أول
ربح مجاني لأنه مجاني
وهو أفضل شيء حدث على الإطلاق
آه في الوقت الحالي ، لذا يرجى الذهاب إليه ،
هذا
كل ما أقول إنك تعرف ما إذا كان بإمكاني القيام بذلك بشكل جيد ،
لذا هل يمكنك فصل الشتاء من السخط الذي جعله
العلم مليئًا بالأمل ولكن لا يوجد
شعر
من وليام شكسبير أو فاتورة
واضحة لأصدقائه
فقط أو من أجل  إنجاز طبي تاريخي
ورائد أعتقد
أنه يمكن أن يحدث فرقًا في حياتنا
من الآن فصاعدًا ، أليس كذلك
عبر المملكة المتحدة ، ألهمت اللكمات
الأولى شعورًا ساحقًا بين أولئك
الذين تلقوها
تهانينا للامتنان ، شكرًا
لك وعاطفة أخرى لموظفي الخدمة الصحية
الوطنية البريطانية الموقرة بالفعل
أنا فخورة جدًا لكوني جزءًا من
NHS الآن في إدنبرة كانت الدكتورة ليندا واتسون
من بين أول الطاقم الطبي الذي
تلقى اللقاح
رسالتها إلى  كن متفائلاً للعام المقبل
ولكن لا تغير السلوكيات حتى الآن ،
ولهذا السبب ما زلت أرتدي قناعًا ، فأنت تعلم
أنه من المهم الحفاظ على التباعد الاجتماعي
والقيام بجميع سلوكيات السلامة
لبضعة أشهر جيدة حتى الآن ، ولكن
هناك الآن تحول إلى الزاوية  الآن
لا يزال هناك الكثير من العمل الذي يتعين القيام به ، لكن
اليوم الأول من برنامج التطعيم الشامل في بريطانيا
كان
عاطفيًا وألهم جهدًا علميًا ولوجستيًا استثنائيًا تم
حشده لحماية الفئات الأكثر ضعفًا في البلاد
وهذا يعني أن مارتن كينيون سيحظى
باحتضان الأشخاص الذين يحبهم
مرة أخرى.  آمل ألا
أعاني من الحشرة الدموية الآن ،
فأنا لا أنوي الحصول عليها لأن
لدي حفيدات وأريد أن أعيش وقتًا
طويلاً للاستمتاع بحياتهم  فيل بلاك سي إن
إدنبرة ،
إنه يوم الخامس هنا ، ربما تكون قد عرفت
أنه يوم النصر ولكن اليوم يطلق عليه بعض
الناس اسم
يوم التطعيم لأن
بدء التشغيل اليوم هذه
هي اللحظة التاريخية
وأول شخص يتلقى لقاحًا
هو مارغريت المعروفة باسم ماجي  حريصة على
أنها جدة
لأم لابنها وابنتها التي استيقظت
مبكرًا وكانت في
السادسة والنصف من عمرها اليوم للحصول على هذه الوظيفة وهي ترتدي سترة
عيد الميلاد الخاصة بها ،
قالت إن هذه هي أفضل
هدية عيد ميلاد مبكرة يمكنني الحصول
عليها لأن ماجي ستكون
تبلغ من العمر 91 عامًا الأسبوع المقبل
وتقول إنها الآن يمكنها أخيرًا أن
تتطلع إلى قضاء المزيد من الوقت مع
أسرتها ، واستمع إلى المزيد مما
كان عليها أن تقوله ،
سأفعل ذلك
لأنه مجاني وهو أفضل شيء  لقد حدث هذا من
قبل
آه في الوقت الحالي ، لذا يرجى الذهاب إليه ،
هذا كل ما أقول
إنك تعرف ما إذا كان بإمكاني القيام بذلك بشكل جيد ،
فهل يمكنك الآن أن تتحلى ماجي بالصبر
على الشخص الثاني الذي يتلقى
اللقاح وأنا أعلم أنه سيبدو كما لو
أماه  ملك هذا ولكن أعدك
أن هذا صحيح هو ويليام شكسبير ، نعم في
الليلة التي كان فيها الشخص الثاني الذي يحمل نفس الاسم للشاعر الإنجليزي الشهير يبلغ من العمر 81 عامًا
، كان محاطًا بعمل فني من
أحفاده عندما حصل
على التطعيم ثم أخذ فيما بعد
استرح ، لكن هاتين
قصتين فقط مؤثرتين للغاية
نسمعهما اليوم عن العديد من الأشخاص
الذين يتلقون
اللقاحات الأولى ومن المهم هنا أن
نتذكر مدى تاريخية هذه اللحظة فقد
أكثر من 60
ألف شخص حياتهم في
البلاد
وهذا كما يقول المسؤول هنا
بداية النهاية ، لذا يبدأ كل شيء
بـ 800000 جرعة موجودة بالفعل
في البلد ، يتم توزيعها
من 50 مركزًا للمستشفيات في جميع أنحاء
إنجلترا والأشخاص الذين
سيعطون الأولوية هم أولئك الذين تزيد أعمارهم عن 80 عامًا
في المستشفى  أو يمكن أن تأتي إلى
المستشفيات بالإضافة إلى العاملين في مجال الرعاية
الصحية ودار رعاية المسنين أو موظفي دار الرعاية
، ستكون
عملية معقدة كبيرة ولكن من أجل الحفارة  ht الآن يسعد
الجميع بهذه
الخطوة الأولى المهمة للغاية سام
عبد
الزيس سي إن إن لندن